[music playing]
ALBERT LIN: It's literally
a city in the clouds.
Maybe those Spanish
stories weren't
just legends because that's what
a real lost city looks like.
HELICOPTER PILOT:
[inaudible] 1 0 1 2.
ALBERT LIN: That's Ciudad
Perdida, the Lost City.
Ciudad Perdida, the
Lost City, is high
up in Colombia's most
isolated mountain range,
the Sierra Nevada.
Archaeologists
have spent decades
exploring this dense jungle to
find out about the people who
lived here over 500 years ago.
Digital technology will help
them reveal more and faster.
[chuckles]
Only the world's
toughest archaeologists
can handle this terrain.
Santiago Giraldo has been
excavating here for 20 years.
[chuckles] It's a
beautiful place.
[helicopter]
It's amazing this place
is still standing.
Who discovered it?
SANTIAGO GIRALDO: It was
like [spanish],, looters.
And then the
archaeologists came in.
Took them about a
week to get here.
And they were led
by other looters.
Looters led the way, huh?
Yeah, it's actually pretty
incredible because they were--
they got into a shotgun fight.
The looters were after the
gold that's in the burials.
And one looter came out with,
you know, more than 80 pieces
of gold from one burial.
Wow.
Yeah.
ALBERT LIN: Gunfights for gold.
Archeology gets dangerous
when gold is involved.
And this place is
bursting with it.
Who built all this?
It was a people that
we call the Tayrona.
Their predecessors,
the [inaudible]
built it around 600 AD.
It's huge.
[music playing]
How many people
would've lived here?
About 2,000 to
3,000 at its peak.
And then about
10,000 people living
in the upper part of the basin.
10,000?
Yeah.
All that forest that you see
would have been all farmland.
Aw, man, you can almost feel
their energy here, you know?
Like all these people
running around.
SANTIAGO GIRALDO: It's taken
us over 40 years of work
to clear out and
survey the site, trying
to tease out what these
people were thinking
when they were building it.
ALBERT LIN: 40 years?
SANTIAGO GIRALDO: Yep.